it seems like the right time to pick up
puss and throw him back to the biggest
screen the place where he belongs my
beautiful beard it is very distinguished
yes this time I think it's even better I
have to give a lot of credit to the
directors it's an ambitious story it's a
story about death but on the flip side
about life how do you make that fun how
do you make that accessible for all
audiences a lot of those ideas came out
of brainstorms we really became like a
little writer's room you just bounce
hundreds of ideas off they want to hear
from everybody what's working or what
isn't working and why the dynamic is
kind of merely like going to the pub
with a bunch of your friends debating on
top of each other trying to come up with
the funniest part trying to one-up
everyone else but done in such a
respectful fun way governor
[Music]